how you're gonna get out of this ain't
cutting up that's okay I don't bring my
cuffs anyway
[Music]
we've got a bank 211 in progress
suspects are armed and they have taken
hostages all units stand down you
watching
yep how you're gonna get out of this
[Music]
you know this is Gd collect dealing with
different hanim here boys
Trading up Los Angeles branch of the
Federal Reserve Bank has never been
robbed that's why we're gonna Rob it
gangbangers these are not the National
Bank Hollywood jobs look good in a gal
you know these guys we solve all these
cases this is the crew it's been visit
do we look like the types who arrest you
we just shoot
you're addicted to Isis sooner or later
I need to fix at the Federal Reserve
billions of dollars are taken out of
circulation if we can break in and steal
those old bills before they're destroyed
we got our hands on money on the case in
the joint from the inside the going
baked hey you know just means means I am
a member of a gang only we have badges
[Music]
you're not the bad guys we are Friday
make sure he knows it's all I'm gonna
let you know now better wear your best
moves you should you understand
goodbye suspects wearing body armor
headshots only on my signal let's go
thank of enough it's okay I bring my
cuffs anyway
you
[Music]
you